[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ محمد اسفنديار دلاور في مدينه
كراتشي الباكستانيه وفيها بدا خطواته
الاولى في حفظ القران الكريم وتعلم اللغه
العربيه قبل انتقاله للدراسه في المدينه
المنوره حيث تلقى علوم القران على يد عدد
من كبار حفاظها وتولى الامامه في عدد من
المساجد قبل تدرجه في المراتب الاكاديميه
ليدرس في عدد من الجامعات الاسلاميه في
باكستان قبل استقراره في ماليزيا مدرسا
بالجامعه الاسلاميه العالميه طبعا نحن كنا
نتعلم القران عندنا في باكستان الطريقه
باننا نتعلم اولا القران الكريم نظرا
فكان هناك احد المشايخ الذي كان يدرسنا
اسمه الشيخ محمد ياسين فهذا الشيخ راح
لقريته ثم جاء بداله رجل اخر والشيخ اخر
فكان يتكلم معنا
بان في شيخ من مصر واسمه الشيخ عبد الباسط
وقرا سوره الرحمن كامله بنفس واحد
طبعا انا استغربت وتشجعت بهذه الفكره
وبقوله فطبعا بدانا بدات الرحله من هناك
يعني مع القران الكريم
ثم اشتريت اشرطه للشيخ عبد الباسط رحمه
الله عليه وبدات
اتدرب صوتي على صوته
وشاركنا في كثير من المسابقات في على
مستوى كراتشي وعلى مستوى يعني باكستان
واخذت المراكز الاول فيها الحمد لله ثم
حفزنا القران
وحفزت القران الكريم وكان عمري تقريبا 12
سنه
وفي خلال سنه
السنه وشهرين يعني في اربعه اربعه عشر
اشهر حفظت القران الكريم كاملا الحمد لله
وبعد ذلك تعلمنا العلوم الشرعيه والادبيه
في كراتشي و ثم ذهبنا الى الجامعه
الاسلاميه وتخرجنا من كليه القران الكريم
طبعا قبل ان اذهب الى كليه القران الكريم
درسته القراءات العشر الحمد لله ثم اخذنا
الاجازات والسند في القراءات العشر
على مشايخنا ثم بعد التخرج من الجامعه
الاسلاميه اتينا هنا الى ماليزيا وعينا
عينت محاضر في قسم التلاوه الحمد لله فهذه
رحله بالايجاز مع القران الكريم طبعا
عندنا في باكستان البيئه هكذا مثلا اذا
واحد يبغى يصير قارئ القران الكريم
فينبغي عليه ان يتقلد
بصوت الشيخ عبد الباسط رحمه الله عليه حتى
لو كان عنده صوت مرتل صوت جميل ولا يستطيع
ان يقرا بالمدرسه المصريه لا يعد من
القراء لازم
ان يحيي الحفلات القرانيه بصوت بصوت الشيخ
عبد الباسط رحمه الله عليه وعلى ما اعتقد
ربما يعني في الستينات الشيخ عبد الباسط
عبد الصمد رحمه الله عليه هو كان من
الاوائل الذي زار باكستان واشتهر
كثيرا حتى تاثر الحفاظ والقراء وتاثروا
بصعوده الى يومنا هذا
ربما يكون السبب الرئيسي لانه من القراء
المصريين الاوائل الذين زاروا باكستان
وتاثر
كثير واخذ التشجيع والشهره من قبل القراء
الباكستانيين هم شجعوا تلامذتهم على هذا
فربما هذا يكون
باعتقادي السبب الرئيسي لشهره المدرسه
المصريه
وطبعا بدات من الشيخ عبد الباسط عبد الصمد
رحمه الله عليه
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
عسى ربكم
ان
يرحمكم
وان عدتم عدنا
وجعلنا
جهنم
للكافرين حصيرا
ان هذا القران
يهدي
للتي هي اقوم
ويبشر المؤمنين
الذين
يعملون
الصالحات
ان لهم
اجرا كبيرا
وان
الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره
اعتدنا لهم
عذابا اليما
ويدع
الانسان بالشر
دعاء
وكان
الانسان عجولا
[موسيقى]
وجعلنا الليل والن
ايتين فمحو
نا يت
فمحو
نا ايه
الليل وجعل
[موسيقى]
ناه
ن وجعل
[ضحك]
نا
ايها النهار
مبصره
لتبتغوا فضلا
من ربكم
ولتعلموا عدد السنين والح
وكل شيء
فصلناه تفصيلا
صدقا
الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على
للقارئ محمد اسفنديارا مجموعه مؤلفات
وتسجيلات في القران وعلومه وبالاضافه الى
التدريس يشرف على انشطه جامعيه ومسابقات
عده تحفز الطلب على حفظ القران الكريم
ومعرفه احكامه وهو حاصل على جوائز كبرى في
الحفظ والتلاوه علم القراءات هو طبعا يعني
علم دقيق جدا يعني يحتاج له رغبه من من
طلبه طلبه خاصه من الحفاظ يعني اذا كان
حافظ وعنده رغبه ويريد ان
يدقق في هذا العلم لان هذا العلم
يحتاج الى الى الحفظ يعني حفظ
كتاب حرز الاماني ووجه التهاني للامام
الشاطبي
رحمه الله عليه
فهذا الكتاب
يبغى له ان يحفظ واحد مثل اسمه لانه
يعلمنا يعني الادله للقراءه مثلا مالك يوم
الدين او مالك يوم فمن يقرا مالك ومن يقرا
مالكي فيقول الامام الشاطبي رحمه الله
كمثال ومالك يوم الدين يرويه ناصر وعند
صراط والسرات لقنبله مثلا مالك يقرا
الامام الكسائي والامام عاصم والباقون
يقراون بملك من القراء السبعه فعلم دقيق
فيحتاج من طلبه العلم ان يحفظوا هذا
الكتاب يعني المتن والمنظومه للامام
الشاطبي واذا اراد ان يدقق اكثر في
القراءات الثلاثه او الذي يقال له السبع
والعشر فعليه ان يحفظ بكتاب الدره الدره
المضيئه للامام ابن الجزري رحمه الله عليه
فطبعا لانه علم يعني علم ليس علم سهل
فنجد ان الطلبه
ياتون الى لتعلم هذا العلم ولكن ليس بهذه
الكثره فهم يكتفون على مثلا على
التلاوه على تلاوه القران الكريم وعلى
تحسين الصوت وعلى تحسين
التجويد وهذه الاشياء طبعا علم القراءات
يبغى له التدقيق واحد كل شيء يتعلق بالحفظ
يعني الذي يقرا ويخلط في القراءات لا
ينبغي له ان يخلق في القراءات الا اذا كان
متمكنا ومتقنا في علم القراءات ودرس علم
القراءات على مشايخ بالاجازه والاسانيد
ويعرف ان يرتب هؤلاء القراء يعني ترتيبا
حسنا في قراءته فلا باس
الروايه الدارجه الذي يروي عن سيدنا
الامام عاصم رحمه الله عليه الكوفي سيدنا
الامام عاصم الكوفي كما طبعا هناك البلدان
الاخرى مثل تونس وليبيا والجزائر
فالجزائر يقرؤون بورش
يعني مراكش يقراون بورش ايضا اما دارجه في
العالم يعني هي روايه سيدنا الامام حفصه
ساقرا لكم ان شاء الله
بقراءه سيدنا الامام كسائي رحمه الله عليه
واقرا سوره الهمزه حتى لان جميع الناس
يحفظونها وحتى يصل عليهم ما هي الاختلافات
للقراءه الاخرى من سيدنا الامام حفصه رحمه
الله عليه اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ويل لكل همزه لمزه
الذي
جمع مالا وعدده
يحسب
انما له
اخلده
كلا لينبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراك ما الحطمه
نار الله الموقد
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها عليهم
موسى
في عمد
ممدده صدق الله
العظيم
هي القراءه يعني التي تقرا في الحفلات
قراءه
بسكينه وطمانينه مع مراعاه احكام التجويد
وتقرا يعني جمله جمله او بعض الاحيان
يقف القاري على مقاطع من الايات
نعم اما القراءه التي تقرا في الصلاه هي
يقال لها قراءه مرتله فتكون اسرع من
القراءه
التي هي قراءه مجوده لان للقراءه هناك
مراتب هناك اربع مراتب للقراءه لقراءه
القران الكريم فطبعا المرتبه الاولى هي
قراءه المرتله وامرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى
ايضا لان يقرا الانسان والمؤمن والمسلم
على هذه القراءه
كما امرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى وقال ورتل
القران ترتيلا فترتيل القراءه قراءه
القران هي ان يقرا الانسان بتاوده
وطمانينه وسكينه مع مراعاه احكام التجويد
فهذا يقال لها القراءه المرتله ثم تاتي
مرتبه قراءه قراءه تدوير تدوير يعني اسرع
من المرتله قليلا ثم تاتي مرتبه
حذر حذر بمعنى يعني ان يقرا القارئ قراءه
اسرع وهذا طبعا هذه المرتبه تناسب مع مع
الحفاظ الذين لهم ورد يومي ويقراون ثلاثه
اجزاء او خمسه اجزاء او جزئين فتناسب
وتقرا حذر
بمد الجائزه المنفصل بمقدار حركتين ثم
التحقيق تاتي هذه المراتب الاربعه
لقراءه القران الكريم طبعا تقرا
في الحفلات قراءه مرتله يعني تقرا بتؤدى
ممكن تعاد الايه الواحده ثلاثه او اربع
مرات
ولكي تدخل في القلوب
وتقربنا الى الله سبحانه وتعالى اما في
التراويح القراءه التي نقراها نقرا
بالتدوير او بالترتيب التسجيل المصحف
يحتاج الى الوقت من القارئ وكذلك من
المخرج
وتنسيق
كخبرتي مع مع التسجيل للمصحف المرتل يعني
هو اعطاء الوقت ان نعطي الوقت الكافي
وطبعا هناك الاشياء الاخرى التي
تخل في هذا ولكن هو لازم يكون عند القارئ
العزم ايضا يعني
فاقرا لكم من سوره الفرقان بضع ايات ان
شاء الله
فعاده نحن نقرا انا اقرا لكم من سوره
الفرقان ان شاء الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تبارك الذي جعل في الس
ماء بروجا وجعل فيها سراجا
وجعل فيها
سراجا وقمرا
منيرا
وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار خلفه لمن اراد ان يذكر
خلفه لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد شكورا
وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض هونا
واذا خاطبهم الجاهلون
واذا خاطبهم الجاهلون قالوا سلاما
والذين يبيتون لربهم سجدا
وقياما
والذين يقول ون ربنا اصرف
عنا عذاب
جهنم
ان عذابها كان غراما
انها
ساءت مستقرا
ومقاما
والذين اذا
انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم يقتروا وكان بين ذلك
قواما
والذين لا يدعون مع الله
الها اخر ولا يقتلون النفس
ولا يقتلون
النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق ولا
يزنون
ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى اثام
ا يضاعف له
العذاب
يضاف له العذاب يوم القيامه
ويخلد فيه مهانا
الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالحا
فاولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم حسنات
فا
[ضحك]
ولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم حسنات
[موسيقى]
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]